yes this footage that you are seeing now
is of jumping on the bus recording me
jogging and there's me thinking that she
has worked so fast new Muslim the
anthers are busted he comes he's ready
to become a Muslim we asked him do you
believe in Allah yes we live in the
Angels yes we love Islam yes how did you
know about Islam they say we read the
English translation of the Quran Karim
all day and again now the limit of
contactless is 45 pounds
what 50 and I left my card my mum's so
hopefully I can use contact this on the
phone oh yeah Dana see how it goes
okay guys so I had to come out the house
to get some essentials written and see
morons are feeling that well and the
answers not work if I was little bit of
running around but coming down these
ends we got to do some rice
keep it down yeah okay
I can't wait long Jackie a look at his
yeah so he's going to get that thing
I'll give you the extra to add some
chicken in there you hear me you know
some of that you know I need you know
the gadgets well yeah somebody's know
what time is fun
yeah ready for this yeah II saw if
you're watching this found you know you
know what time is allowed somebody feed
we had ever since probably looking for
some attitude everywhere so if I smuggle
a gallery before the feds come you get
me report
under control anybody want Somali food
call my name is quite emotional normally
and then when he told you he's open
every day during take you away and then
when you ask him for a spoon it gives
you a real one that's real love
yeah I try to do it killing me get half
and then rest and then limit half back
but today what I'm gonna do it I'm going
also incorporate press stops about 120
press ups okay that's all away from my
wife she calls me on FaceTime nothing
and she's walking here she's jumped in
her friend's car and a friend dropped
her but dropped in the wrong places I
know she has to walk here you see she
plans on Allah plans and I was the best
planner when you try to run away from
exercise
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you are finished with your exercise
you need to repent to your home
so guys she was supposed to run with me
on the way to the park but she cheated
and jumped in a friend's car I fall at
least on the way back she would at least
be walking back so I told her you walk
ahead I'm gonna drop I'll see you at the
other side and this footage that you are
seeing now is of her jumping on the bus
recording me dropping and there's me
thinking that she has walked so fast
well she gets on the bus stop and then I
cropped and then guess what's happened
[Music]
[Music]
so if you guys have a god to make the
most of it so if you have a washing line
like this yeah so what you can do is use
in boxing we have like a rope and we use
it for you know it's what my teacher
taught by the I'm not professional I'm
just tell you what's been told to me
yeah so you can use it
one two three four it's more legs but
it's body movement as well
one two so you see my attacks you know
with Mike Tyson butch was bill your
position and he starts knocking out
people yet so it's very good for little
movements you know a lot of people think
boxing is about you know strength etc
one of the reasons I've got this club on
here and not on here cuz I'm just doing
this is just shadow boxing and the
reason being this is what was taught to
me once again I'm not professional not
claiming to be we see this our power
punch yes well this is like the reason
so I've got more two hands this is seen
there's a you know we call you know
gonna do much for this and this your
power punch so this is where you look
out the person however the thing is I
watch the box in my shoulders watched on
YouTube you know the Irish gypsies here
so when they were fighting there was a
guy there and he literally damaged his
opponent so much without using his power
punch it was all about jobs jab jab jab
jab jab jab jab and well his face was
bloody I'm trying to find a video this
is a bare-knuckle fight that I can kind
of get into
maleeni yes jabs yeah it's just a job
he's gonna doing a good job pairing yeah
look at the distance or bloody it up the
job are just basic jobs just basic jazz
we do not condone that
Niva is boxing about going out then
knocking people out yeah
the gypsies they have their way of
dealing with matters which I actually
admire which is that he in the beta
which is haraam bombs in in a way they
don't go stuff in each other shooting
each other you've got a problem 101
that's it leave it best man wins now one
thing that I was taught from my teachers
is well it's when we usually before what
are the mistakes that I would make is
when you're going to a fight for example
if you need to need to you can fight
fighter or course yeah I'm not a fire
I'm a peacemaker let's make love you
know of course but so basically would
happen is you're in a fight yeah you're
this you're doing that you know you got
something to fight like this you know in
America you know but the thing is one
thing they taught me is protect your
chin yeah so that's what you see with
boxes is that when they're fighting when
they for the job yeah
your legs are important as well so what
they do is before we like this people
fight like this what would being told is
look for my this side if I fall a job
and it misses and that person who comes
to this side he's gonna throw a right I
know how about if I do this do you see
you see right here my chin so first I'll
be a bit closer so if I was to do this
much exposed I can get hit anyway yeah
however when you're doing it so for
example if I do this I'm taking this
yeah you're doing but so when you're
punching your chin is protected and not
only that
so from here once you do that bang yeah
now protect your chin so you're guarded
yes if he was to punch you especially
with a lot boxes the the the glove
bounces off the shoulder yes protect
yourself and once you do that so your
hands in this motion once you punch
protect Yeah right
cuz you don't know he might slip this
side any side of your body so you've got
your elbow to protect ya
so this is some of the things that my
teachers taught me to have that yes this
is the powerful mr. Pao shot and usually
most of the times people just do that it
comes from the feet we move your feet
with it and when we do that as you can
see when I cut and I hit him and I want
to knock him out
bang I want to protect my chin
constantly my chin is in protection
always always in protection
now we're not seen in a real fight
boxing when that happens you know it's
gonna be you're gonna calculate you are
going to be a job and then I wear this
in one sense yeah but if you
subconsciously memorize this your body
won't go to this motion is shallow just
watch it out with you guys once again
we're not here to condone fighting you
avoid fighting that every cost it's just
it was training that I've been doing
I've been taught by my teachers and what
professional thank you goodbye